J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, ben, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour. Aujourd'hui, un épisode qui concerne encore une fois le féminisme et encore une fois avec une invitée française puisque je reçois
Lauren Bastide, podcasteuse de renom, journaliste de renom, autrice de renom, que vous avez certainement pu voir partout sur les plateaux télé et
dans les podcasts en France.
Son podcast le plus connu étant évidemment La Poudre, euh, pu-publié chez, euh, en exclusivité sur Spotify. Et on a passé septante minutes ensemble pour parler de son nouveau livre Futur, publié chez Allary Éditions.
C'est la suite du livre Présente qu'elle avait sorti il y a deux ans déjà. Je ne vous en dis pas plus. Vous allez voir que cet épisode réserve quelques surprises inattendues.
Euh, et enfin, vous avez certainement remarqué qu'il n'y a plus trop d'épisodes depuis déjà un mois. Je suis complètement à la bourre en termes de publication.
Toutes mes excuses à ce niveau-là. Je vous explique à la fin de l'épisode le pourquoi du comment. Bonne écoute. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être rejoint par Lauren Bastide. Bonjour Lauren.
Bonjour Guillaume.
Euh, tu es ici à Bruxelles depuis deux jours. Comment ça se passe pour toi jusqu'à présent ? Est-ce que tu, est-ce que tu profites bien de notre beau paysage bruxellois ?
Mais ouais, j'suis tellement bien ici. C'est-- j'adore Bruxelles, en fait. À chaque fois que je viens, j'aime un peu plus.
C'est vrai ?
Et je trouve que les gens sont tellement intelligents.
C'est un peu de la démagogie, ça. Tu essayes de me séduire.
Je te jure, euh, y a cette espèce de truc, l'humour, cet esprit, en fait, où je-- à chaque fois que j'arrive en Belgique, je suis, je suis obligée de, de, d'annuler cette espèce de truc où,
où par défaut à Paris, tu penses que tu vas parler à quelqu'un de pas très gentil et de pas très bienveillant.
Ok.
Et en fait, ici, tu te rends compte que les gens sont plutôt bienveillants, plutôt, plutôt-- ben, en tout cas drôles et fins.
Et euh, et j'aime-- ouais, je m'y sens hyper bien. Je dois finir par venir me réfugier, devenir réfugiée politique à Bruxelles.
Donc, tu es ici dans le cadre de la promo pour ton livre Futur, qui suit ton livre précédent Présente, que tu as sorti il y a deux ans.
Euh, dans le premier livre, tu prenais la température du monde, de la société dans lequel on évolue. Tu exposais la situation, par exemple, des femmes voilées, par exemple, des femmes trans.
Euh, et tu, tu exposais un petit peu la, la situation telle qu'elle est. Dans le deuxième, tu touches à des sujets plus radicaux.
Si-- corrige-moi si, si tu veux me reprendre. Plus radicaux, plus politiques comme, euh, l'hétéronormatisation, hum, le féminisme anti-carcéral, des choses plus, comment dire, euh, plus inconnues du grand public.
Donc, et surtout, je me, je me souviens que dans le premier livre, tu prenais très fort la main du, du, du lecteur, oui, du lecteur surtout, en lui disant : « Mais ne t'inquiète pas, on-- tout va bien se passer.
Euh, ça te choque peut-être de lire ce que je suis en train de dire, mais dans un instant, on va, on va voir, on va voir qu'en fait, y a, y a pas de quoi s'inquiéter.
» Hum, et dans le deuxième, effectivement, je sens plus de, plus de radicalité. Est-ce que, est-ce que tu es d'accord avec ce terme-là ?
Euh, pas forcément.
Ok.
Euh, pas forcément. En tout cas, euh, les questions que je portais dans Présente, c'était des questions éminemment politiques.
Bien sûr.
Euh, parler de, d'espace public, parler de médias, parler d'intersectionnalité, qui étaient vraiment les thématiques qui étaient le plus mises en avant dans Présente.
Euh, c'est des sujets qui sont très politiques. Euh, prendre,
euh, expliquer, euh, que faire preuve d'un certain paternalisme vis-à-vis des femmes musulmanes qui portent le voile et euh, et qu'on peut, voilà, envisager les choses différemment,
euh, de ce qui est généralement envisagé quand on parle d'elles en France, ça peut être considéré comme une posture radicale.
D'ailleurs, je me fais ab-ab-abondamment insulter pour avoir pris ces positions, euh, régulièrement dans l'espace public.
Mmm-hmm.
Disons, dans Futur, peut-être que je vais, euh, plus dans, dans la pensée théorique féministe.
Ok.
Peut-être que la, que la différence, c'est ça, c'est que-- et peut-être aussi que je, j'amène à la connaissance du grand public des, des théories qui sont moins connues.
Mmm-hmm. Oui, c'est ça.
Voilà.
Tu, tu vas chercher plus dans, comment dire-- il faut, il faut être, euh-- avoir connaissance des auteurs comme-
Ouais.
Lauren Bas-- euh, pas Lauren Bastide. Comme Monique Wittig, voilà, je-
Oui.
Je confonds.
C'est ça.
Oui, oui, c'est vrai que, euh, je pense que c'est aussi tout simplement le fruit de, ben de-- 'fin, voilà, quand j'ai commencé à écrire Présente, on était en 2019.
Euh, là, j'ai commencé à écrire Futur deux ans plus tard quoi. Et, et entre-temps, c'est vrai que j'ai moi-même interviewé beaucoup de chercheurs, chercheuses.
J'ai beaucoup réfléchi à ces questions. J'ai lu beaucoup plus de livres, donc c'est aussi-
Oui.
Un livre écrit par une personne qui a une connaissance peut-être plus complexe et plus approfondie des choses. Mais, mais pour revenir sur cette notion de radicalité, euh, je pense qu'il faut vraiment, euh, aussi redonner son sens premier à ce terme.
Mmm-hmm.
Euh, la radicalité, ça, ça veut dire vraiment s'in-- s'attaquer à la racine des choses.
Et euh, et le féminisme, par définition, est une démarche radicale.
Toujours d'accord.
C'est-à-dire, voilà, aller s'attaquer à la racine du problème, euh, en nommant la binarité et la construction sociale du genre, euh, c'est une démarche qui, de toute façon, euh, n'est pas tiède.
C'est une démarche Qui est par définition radicale.
C'est certain. Et je ne voulais certainement pas laisser entendre ça. Euh, et donc tu expliquais donc deux ans se sont écoulés entre ton premier et ton deuxième livre, euh, avec bien sûr une petite pandémie entre entre les deux.
Entre-temps pour nous divertir.
Tu évoques, euh, dans, dans, dans ton livre qu'il y a notamment un chapitre en particulier que, euh, tu as mis six mois à attaquer.
Tu as pris le temps de, de bien, euh, t'y préparer.
Le chapitre qui parle du viol. Euh, et tu dis : ''Le viol, c'est du pouvoir, les hommes violent, les hommes sont violés aussi.'' Tu dis beaucoup de choses, rien qu'en, rien qu'en ces quelques, en ces quelques mots.
Euh, alors, on va s'attaquer au sujet et je vais, je vais, je vais, je vais, je vais faire ça en posant une question, euh, courte mais complexe.
Que faire des hommes accusés d'agression sexuelle ?
Oh là !
Là oui, elle fait peur cette question.
Bah, c'est, c'est...
Mais on va prendre le temps.
Non, mais la-- c'est une question qui est pertinente. Évidemment, c'est la question que tout le monde se pose.
Mh.
Euh, aujourd'hui, enfin, en tout cas, je pense que là, après cinq ans après MeToo, quand on voit, euh, que ça représente beaucoup beaucoup de monde, on est en droit de se poser cette question.
Euh, et cette question, elle est importante. Euh, et je pense que justement, ces trois phrases, alors, je l'ai dit séparément, je précise.
Je, je dis d'une part que le viol, c'est de la domination. Euh, et ça, je le dis pour, pour essayer de, de décorréler viol et sexualité.
Où j'ai l'impression que dans les médias, en fait, surtout dans les médias français, je pense, où vraiment, on sent qu'il y a une crainte profonde de, de, on va perdre l'art de la séduction, on va perdre le droit de draguer les femmes, etc.
Non, non, quand on parle de viol, on parle d'un, d'un outil de domination qui s'exerce certes sur les femmes par les hommes, mais qui s'exerce aussi en temps de guerre, qui s'exerce aussi dans le cadre de la police, dans les prisons, etc.
Enfin, c'est, c'est, c'est-- le viol, c'est autre chose qu'une espèce de, de... Enfin, comme parfois dans les médias français, on peut l'entendre, une espèce de séduction qui déraperait ou...
Oui, c'est ça. Donc des Franz-Olivier Giesbert qui vont expliquer que les femmes qui sont rejointes par un producteur de cinéma savent un petit peu à quoi s'attendre, ce genre de choses, que finalement, c'est pas très surprenant.
C'est exactement à ça que je fais allusion. Euh, donc ça, ce serait quand même bien qu'on commence par comprendre de quoi on parle quand on parle de viol.
Euh, les hommes violent, oui, je le dis, il faut le répéter, il faut assumer cette phrase généraliste parce que oui, les hommes violent.
Mh.
Beaucoup d'hommes violent et en tant que femme, on est en droit de se méfier des hommes parce que,
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'hommes qui violent, il y a beaucoup d'hommes qui agressent, qui harcèlent et, et quatre-vingt seize pour cent des viols sont commis par des hommes.
Voilà. Donc là, on repose bien-
On est en droit de généraliser.
Oui.
Mais, euh, j'ai aussi envie de dire les hommes sont violés.
Euh, et ça, c'est très important aussi de le dire et je pense que ça peut nous aider aussi à avancer sur cette question du viol,
euh, que de, que de rappeler que dans le cadre de MeToo Inceste en France, en tout cas, je ne sais pas si ce, ce hashtag, il a aussi émergé en Belgique.
Certainement, oui.
Mais en tout cas, voilà, il y a une conversation qui a commencé avec Laure sur l'inceste et dans le cadre de cette conversation, on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait beaucoup de petits garçons qui étaient violés.
Puis, à partir de là, je me suis rendu compte que si on commence à,
à penser à ces hommes qui sont violés, je me suis rappelée du, du jeune Théo, qui est un,
un, un jeune homme issu des quartiers populaires, un jeune homme noir, euh, qui s'est vu introduire une matraque dans l'anus par un policier dans le cadre d'un contrôle qui avait dégénéré, entre guillemets, bah, ça, c'est un viol.
Mh.
Euh, et puis dans ce compte, on voit arriver des nouvelles d'Ukraine
et on voit que l'armée russe viole massivement les Ukrainiennes, des femmes, des enfants, des petites filles, des grands-mères, mais aussi des Ukrainiens, mais aussi des, des hommes qui subissent des sévices sexuels.
Donc en fait, on se commence à se poser la question de finalement, cette question du viol et des personnes qui sont victimes de viol, ce sont aussi des hommes en fait.
Donc à chaque fois qu'on présente le, le MeToo comme une espèce de guerre des femmes contre les hommes, on présente, on, on, on échoue en fait à dire ce qu'on, de ce dont on est en train de parler.
Et c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu poser tout ça dans un premier temps.
Et je pense que, et c'est pour ça aussi que, excuse-moi, j'ai voulu redévelopper avant de répondre à ta question, parce que
je crois que pour répondre à la question que tu m'as posée de façon un peu abrupte, pourquoi il y a des hommes qui violent, mais tu as raison hein,
à un moment donné, il faut la poser, il faut d'abord redire tout ça.
Oui.
Et euh...
Tout à fait.
Et, et c'est aussi pour ça que je pense que quand on prend conscience vraiment du caractère massif et systémique du viol, on ne peut plus, euh, vraiment sereinement envisager qu'on va pouvoir aller identifier un par un
les violeurs, les agresseurs, les prédateurs, comme on les appelle parfois aussi bien dans la presse que dans les milieux militants.
Et moi, j'aime, j'aime pas qu'on dise les, qu'on dise les choses comme ça, qu'on va pouvoir les identifier, les extraire à la pince à épiler, les mettre hors d'état de nouir, de nuire et puis pouvoir vivre heureux, heureuse
dans un monde qui sera enfin débarrassé des, des, des violences.
Euh, ça, ça ne marche pas comme ça. Euh, on ne pourra jamais mettre tous les violeurs en prison.
Mh. C'est à ça que je veux arriver, oui.
Ça n'est pas possible.
Mh.
Euh, les prisons sont déjà complètement surpeuplées. Euh, actuellement, il y a zéro virgule six pour cent des viols qui aboutissent à une condamnation pénale.
Euh, il faut aussi admettre que la loi qui punit de quinze ans de prison
le viol est une loi théorique qui n'est pas appliquée et qui ne parvient pas à dissuader qui que ce soit de violer, qu'on a échoué à éradiquer le viol de la société avec cette loi.
Donc à partir de là, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Euh, ça, j'ai pas la réponse. Euh, et c'est important aussi de rappeler que cette,
cette, cette réflexion sur la, la, la justice réparatrice Ce mouvement féministe anti-carcéral, euh, qu'on va, qui va être incarné par Angela Davis, par exemple, euh, qui a écrit : Est-ce que les prisons sont obsolètes ?
Mais aussi par une chercheuse, Gwenola Ricordeau, dont, dont je tiens à systématiquement référencer le travail quand on m'interroge là-dessus, parce que c'est elle qui m'a éveillée à toutes ces questions.
Et elles le disent bien, voilà, il va falloir plusieurs générations, il va falloir beaucoup de temps pour trouver des, des, des véritables réponses précises à comment on fait.
Mais en revanche, ce sur-- ce, ce dont je suis sûre, c'est que les-- le système pénal, le système carcéral, actuellement, ne fonctionne pas.
Donc, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? C'est, c'est-- Je pose la question, en fait, à la société dans son ensemble et, et j'aimerais bien en fait que cette question arrive sur le tapis et fasse vraiment l'objet d'une interrogation.
Ouais. Et donc, la, la piste que tu proposes, que tu évoques, donc, c'est la piste anti-carcérale. Donc cette idée comme quoi, plutôt que de passer par les prisons qui sont donc,
par exemple, aux États-Unis, mais pas seulement, euh, je crois qu'il y a un grand pourcentage de la population américaine qui est actuellement incarcérée.
Euh, et, euh, c'est, c'est principalement, ce sont principalement les hommes racisés qui sont concernés par ces choses-là.
Donc, il y a encore une fois une violence systémique, une oppression sur certaines, certaines populations en particulier.
Et surtout, tu exprimes que les personnes qui sont victimes, les personnes qui sont dans l'entourage des victimes
ne sont en fait pas du tout soulagées, ne sont pas, euh, ne se sentent pas mieux une fois qu'elles savent leur, leur agresseur ou l'agresseur de leur proche derrière les barreaux.
Euh, du coup, ce que tu, ce que tu évoques, c'est le pardon, la discussion ?
Alors, euh, en tout cas, il y a cette, cette voie qu'on appelle la justice réparatrice, euh, et qui, euh, permet-- alors, y a, y a plein de façons de l'envisager.
C'est pas forcément d'ailleurs présenté comme une alternative à la prison. Euh, en France, la justice réparatrice commence à se développer.
Alors, c'est vraiment très timide hein. Voilà, en deux mille vingt, je crois qu'il y a quarante-deux personnes qui en ont bénéficié sur sept cent mille procès au pénal.
Donc, on voit vraiment que c'est, c'est des, c'est des petits pas de, de fourmi. Euh, mais, euh, en tout cas qui viennent--
c'est des, c'est des gestes qui viennent non pas se substituer à la prison et au parcours pénal classique, mais, mais le compléter.
Et dans le cadre de cette réflexion sur la justice réparatrice, on va pro-- on va provoquer des rencontres entre des auteurs de violence et des personnes qui ont été victimes de violence.
Euh, alors, on, on se-- d'après ce que j'ai compris, ça n'est pas, euh, 'fin, c'est jamais des personnes qui sont concernées par le même dossier.
C'est-à-dire qu'on ne va pas faire rencontrer une femme qui a été violée par son violeur, euh, mais par contre, une femme qui a été violée, on va rentrer quelqu'un qui a été condamné pour viol.
Et il sort de ces rencontres un sentiment de réparation,
euh, puisque, euh, au bout de, de plusieurs de ces rendez-vous, y a, y a des études hein, qui ont été, qui ont été faites, les victimes, euh, atteignent un certain niveau d'apaisement,
euh, puisqu'elles ont l'a-- accès en fait à, à des personnes, elles peuvent leur poser des questions elles-mêmes.
Dans, dans le système pénal, les victimes posent jamais les questions elles-mêmes hein. C'est les juges, c'est les, c'est les avocats, c'est les procureurs.
Donc, elles peuvent poser des questions à l'auteur de violence. Elles peuvent trouver en fait des réponses à, à ce qu'il est tarot d'une vie entière.
Pourquoi il a fait ça ? Qu'est-ce qui, qu'est-ce qui se passe dans la tête de quelqu'un qui accomplit une, une telle violence ?
Mais il y a aussi une réparation pour l'auteur de violence qui d'un seul coup est réhumanisé, qui d'un seul coup voit quelqu'un lui dire bonjour.
Et, et il y a eu un podcast que je recommande vraiment d'écouter parce que, parce que je sais que ça déroute quand je dis ça.
Et que, et que bien souvent, on me dit : Ah là là, elle est hors sol, elle est folle, elle est bisounours et tout. Mais il faut écouter cet épisode de Un podcast à soi de Charlotte Bienaimé,
ou-- qui s'appelle d'ailleurs comme ça : Que faire des hommes violents ?
Et où en fait, où on entend un auteur de violence dire, euh : il se rend à, je crois qu'il y a trois rencontres et il dit : La première rencontre, elles m'ont pas serré la main, elles m'ont pas dit bonjour.
Euh, la deuxième rencontre, elles m'ont dit bonjour, elles m'ont serré la main. Et la troisième rencontre, elles m'ont souri quand je suis rentré parce que j'avais tissé un lien et j'avais à nouveau l'impression d'être un être humain.
Ben moi, je suis plutôt rassurée.
Euh, je, je, je pense que cet homme-là, quand il va sortir de prison et réintégrer la société, il y a peut-être plus de chances qu'il réitère pas son, son geste,
euh, plutôt qu'un violeur qu'on aurait laissé croupir pendant vingt ans, quinze ans, puisque c'est quinze ans,
dans une cellule sans jamais lui donner l'opportunité de, de peut-être exprimer une forme de repentir ou de, ou de, d'être explicité son geste.
Donc, il y a vraiment l'idée que les personnes incarcérées sont mises en marge, sont mises à part, sont exclues de la société
et que ça ne peut pas être un bienfait pour leur santé mentale, pour leur bien-être, pour, pour, pour leur réin-réintégration dans la société.
Évidemment. Et puis, je pense que c'est tout-- intuitivement, tout le monde le sait quoi. Euh, 'fin, je sais pas, parfois, je prends cette métaphore qui est, qui est, je pense, parle à tout le monde.
Quand on a un enfant qui fait une bêtise, on lui dit pas : Dégage, connard, va dans un placard et sors dans une heure quand t'auras compris.
Non, on s'assoit à côté de lui, on lui explique pourquoi son geste était, était pas un bon geste en espérant que petit à petit, il s'améliore et qu'il ne le reproduise plus.
Euh, c'est comme ça qu'on éduque quelqu'un. Bon bah, je pense que si on ne fait pas preuve d'un minimum, alors, d'écoute, en tout cas, j'allais-- je vais pas non plus dire de douceur hein.
Je dis pas qu'il faut faire des câlins aux, aux hommes violents, mais, mais par contre, qu'il faut absolument qu'à un moment donné, il y ait une possibilité de dialogue et que cette perspective de retisser le lien entre la société et ces,
ces personnes existe.
Sinon, euh, sinon, je vois pas comment on pourrait se sentir en sécurité, en fait.
Donc ça, là, là, on parle des hommes incarcérés, des hommes qui ont été jugés. Encore une fois, on parle d'une ultra-minorité en ce qui concerne les, les agressions sexuelles.
Quand on parle des personnes qui font simplement partie de notre entourage, de l'entourage des femmes et qu'on sait, euh, très certainement, très probablement, euh, coupables de, de, d'agression sexuelle ou d'agression tout court,
qu'est-ce qu'on--, quelle est la démarche que tu conseilles à ces femmes-là ?
Euh, alors j'essaye de pas, euh, conseiller et j'essaye de pas commencer de phrases par il faut ou on devrait parce que-
Tu proposes.
Ouais, je propose, euh, disons, je, je, je suggère un horizon, euh, plus ou moins lointain vers lequel il me semblerait intéressant de tendre.
Pardon de prendre toutes ces pincettes.
Mais je comprends.
Mais en fait, euh, je veux surtout pas, euh, dire aux femmes qui sont en colère, euh, qui ont envie de hacher menu des hommes qui sont en mode Valérie Solanas et qui veulent tout cramer.
Je veux pas être la personne qui leur dise : Calmez-vous mesdames. Parce que non, la colère est légitime, la misandrie est légitime.
On a le droit de détester les hommes, mais vraiment quoi, aussi longtemps que nécessaire.
On a le droit, mais, mais tu proposes une alternative.
Mais en tout cas, moi, je pense que cette colère, euh, au final, on en sort, euh, presque automatiquement parce que cette colère, elle consume de l'intérieur, elle est épuisante et qu'à un moment donné, euh,
on, on est obligé, ne serait-ce que pour sa santé mentale, de trouver une sorte d'issue, une sorte d'apaisement
pour pouvoir s'en libérer.
Et euh, et puis surtout, euh, je me suis rendu compte qu'on se retrouve tous et toutes à un moment donné dans notre entourage, confrontés à, euh, voilà, un mail, un message qui arrive dans notre boîte un beau matin.
Voilà cet homme que tu côtoies, euh, il a agressé, euh, il a harcelé, il a eu des comportements problématiques, on va dire entre, entre guillemets.
Et dans ces cas-là, qu'est-ce qu'on fait
? Euh, et il me semble que justement parce que ce système de punition et d'exclusion a tendance à ériger en, en monstre, en fait, euh, ces hommes,
euh, on va avoir une réaction de panique soi-même et euh, et finalement couper tous les ponts, unfollow sur les réseaux sociaux, bloquer le numéro de téléphone, dire ok, je lui parle plus jamais parce que c'est comme si d'un seul coup cette,
cette révélation faisait de lui une personne infréquentable.
Moi, ce que j'ai tendance à penser, c'est que, et d'ailleurs, je l'ai constaté, c'est, c'est je vais aller sur un terrain extrêmement épineux de, de ce côté-là, mais c'est vraiment que le reflet de mon expérience personnelle.
Quand on connaît quelqu'un depuis vingt ans,
euh, si on nous révèle que cette personne a eu un comportement violent, ça n'efface pas du jour au lendemain les souvenirs qu'on a avec lui, les émotions, euh, de sympathie, de tendresse qu'on peut avoir pour lui.
Et finalement, un, un ami qui a violé, euh, bah, ça reste en fait quelqu'un qu'on connaît bien. Euh, on peut pas du jour au lendemain arrêter de lui, de lui souhaiter du bien en réalité.
Certains y arrivent, mais toi, tu n'y arrives pas en tout cas.
Bah, en tout cas, je, je, je constate que c'est très insatisfaisant. C'est-à-dire que si, si je coupe tous les ponts et d'ailleurs c'est ce que j'ai fait, c'est quasiment systématiquement.
Si je coupe tous les ponts avec cette personne, j'ai l'impression qu'en fait j'ai pas résolu le problème. Euh, je, je ne sais pas quel effet ça va produire sur lui de se retrouver d'un seul coup du jour au lendemain, sans soutien, sans amis, euh,
sans personne en fait pour euh...
Enfin, c'est, c'est hyper, hyper touchy et j'ai pas non plus envie de dire allez faire des câlins à vos violeurs, ça va s'arranger.
C'est absolument pas ce que je suis en train de dire. Euh, en revanche, je pense que, euh, si, euh, on arrivait à, à, à
réexpliquer l'agression sexuelle et le viol, tout comme on pourrait expliquer, euh, le racisme ou le sexisme ou le validisme, euh, comme des comportements systémiques ancrés dans nos pratiques culturelles qui ne s'exercent jamais seuls.
C'est jamais des histoires de trajectoire individuelle, c'est des histoires de complicité, des histoires de, de terreaux sociaux qui, qui permettent à ces comportements de, d'exister.
Bah peut-être qu'on pou-- on pourrait créer un monde où ces hommes qui ont agressé, euh, auraient l'espace de dire : J'ai agressé, j'ai merdé.
Est-ce que vous voulez bien me pardonner ? Est-ce-- qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour réparer ? Mais cet espace-là n'existe pas pour l'instant.
Le viol s'ancre dans un contexte, dans les systèmes que tu évoquais, sexistes notamment, euh, mais c'est aussi une violence, une faute morale, donc qui blesse.
Euh, et pour être en mesure, enfin là, c'est moi qui
Ouais, mais c'est super intéressant, j'adore débattre avec toi, trop bien.
Je, je, c'est pas un débat, mais c'est pour, pour,
comment dire, pour être en mesure, pour que la victime et l'agresseur soient, euh, tu exprimais que c'était insatisfaisant de complètement bloquer, déjà que t'as quelqu'un de sa vie pour trouver une finalité plus, plus saine,
il faut une conscientisation, il faut du regret de la part du, de l'agresseur ?
Ah probablement.
C'est pas toujours le cas, voilà.
Probable-probablement.
Oui.
Mais, euh, mais, mais je, je pense qu'il y a plus de chances d'obtenir cette conscientisation et ce regret en lui parlant que quand on cesse de décrocher son téléphone quand il appelle.
Mh.
Mais encore une fois, euh, peut-être que je fais preuve de naïveté quand je dis ça, euh, peut-être qu'il y a des personnes qui sont irrécupérables et fondamentalement mauvaises en fait.
Je su-j'ai tendance à pas vouloir penser ça.
Je comprends.
Mais je me trompe peut-être. Je me trompe peut-être. J'ai aucune certitude à ce sujet. Euh, néanmoins, ce, ce dont je suis sûre, c'est qu'on pourrait imaginer créer un monde où, euh, une personne qui a exercé des violences aurait un espace Euh, pour s'avancer
et, et à manifester une volonté de rédemption.
Or cet espace-là, aujourd'hui, n'existe pas parce qu'on a tendance à présenter les viols et les violeurs comme des personnes déviantes et monstrueuses alors que non, je répète, le viol, c'est partout et c'est tout le temps.
C'est ça. Oui, il faut avant tout voir le système-
Voilà.
Et pas voir la, la faute comme intrinsèquement faisant partie d'une personne isolée, euh.
C'est un peu ça que j'essaie de dire, ouais.
Oui, oui, on se comprend très bien. C'est super. Euh, donc là, le chapitre du viol effectivement est un chapitre important dans, dans ton livre.
Tu évoques énormément d'autres choses. Euh, un autre aspect que tu évoques dans ton-- dans un autre chapitre, c'est, euh, les questions liées au racisme, au classisme notamment.
Tu prends l'exemple des, des aides ménagères, euh, et tu cites Caroline Ibos. Et tu dis encore une fois que ce n'est pas une faute morale que d'employer une aide ménagère, mais des mécanismes structurels qui traversent, euh, nos sociétés.
Du coup, des personnes bourgeoises, privilégiées qui sont en situation d'employer une, une aide-ménagère. Encore une fois, qu'est-ce que tu leur conseilles ?
Bah encore une fois, je vais pas, j'ai pas envie de commencer des phrases par il faut ou par on devrait, etc. etc.
C'est ma faute.
Euh, en tout cas, je trouve qu'il y a... Enfin, je sais pas, j'ai envie de te retourner la question en fait.
Je t'en prie.
Toi, t'es un, un, un garçon, un homme dont manifestement, euh, voilà, qui a, qui a-- on m'a dit en tout cas,
je dis, on a, on a des amis, on a des amis en commun
qui m'ont dit que tu étais un véritable allié féministe, que tu avais pris conscience de tout un tas de, de, de, de mécanismes systémiques qui oppressaient les femmes, notamment dans le cadre du cyberharcèlement.
Manifestement, t'as lu, t'as lu mes livres, t'as pris le temps de comprendre et de réfléchir à ces questions. Donc maintenant que t'as compris ça, qu'est-ce qui, qu'est-ce que, qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Bien joué.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Je me prends à mon propre piège.
Oui, oui, parce que c'est pareil en réalité.
J'ai effectivement une, une aide-ménagère et effectivement, et je te pose la question en partie parce que je ne sais pas quoi faire.
Je te demandais pas au sujet des aides ménagères, je te demandais simplement qu'est-ce que tu faisais pour les femmes aujourd'hui.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Tu, tu, t'as, t'as pas, t'as probablement pas fondamentalement changé ta façon de relationner avec les femmes, t'as probablement pas-
Fondamentalement...
Mais t'as, mais t'as aussi certainement réfléchi et, et fait des choses qui te permettent juste de tenir compte du fait que t'es au courant que le sexisme existe aujourd'hui.
Peut-être, t'as accordé ton soutien à des femmes dans des moments difficiles, peut-être que tu t'es dit tiens, je vais me renseigner, je vais comprendre.
Qu'est-ce que t'as fait concrètement maintenant que tu, que t'es un garçon féministe ?
Euh, alors déjà, déjà, je, on m'a, on m'a, on m'a expliqué très gentiment que je ne pouvais surtout pas m'approprier le terme féminisme parce que c'est plutôt l'affaire des femmes.
Il y a, il y a, tout le monde est, tout le monde n'est pas d'accord à ce sujet.
Moi, je trouve qu'un homme peut être féministe.
Oui, moi, j'ose plus parce que-
J'aimerais bien d'ailleurs.
On m'a tellement, on s'est tellement fâché sur moi quand, quand je disais que j'étais féministe. Maintenant, je le fais plus trop.
Mais euh, mais euh, et donc ta question, c'était qu'est-ce que, qu'est-ce que ça a changé, qu'est-ce que, au niveau de mes actions ?
Mais alors figure-toi que, oh, là, je vais raconter ma vie. Figure-toi qu'il y a pas longtemps, j'étais en, en date Tinder avec une fille et on discute, on discute, on discute et à un moment donné surgissent des aspects plus politiques.
Et j'ai entendu, euh, ben j'ai eu la chance justement d'interviewer Maryline Battou-Mattis il y a, il y a deux ans, quelque chose comme ça.
Et, et cette, cette personne, ce date avec qui j'étais me disait
: mais oui, mais moi, je crois que vraiment, il y a des différences biologiques ancrées, qu'on n'est pas les mêmes et que forcément, les rôles sont pas tout à fait les mêmes, elle me disait chasseur-cueilleur, tout ça, tout ça, tout ça.
Et, et c'est très, c'est très compliqué parce que j'ai pas envie de lui expliquer la vie. J'ai pas envie de lui dire : mais non, mais moi, j'ai interviewé Maryline Battou-Mattis, je sais mieux que toi
quelle est, quelle est ta place ou quelle est ma place ou quels sont les rôles des femmes et des hommes, machin. Donc c'est...
Ce que, ce qui est certain, c'est que ça, ça, ça change ma grille de lecture quand j'écoute les hommes et dans ce cas-ci une femme, euh,
et j'ai tendance à vouloir subtilement conseiller, tiens, mais est-ce que tu ne lirais pas ce livre que, que j'ai justement, que je peux te proposer ?
Bon, c'est très subtil. Ce, moi, je me, je me réfugie en me disant que j'interviewe, que je donne un, une place, une estrade, un podium à des personnalités qui tiennent des discours plus inclusifs, voilà.
Bon, alors est-ce que ça change ma vie à moi ? Je pense, j'espère. Ça pourrait la changer plus certainement et je continue à me poser des questions.
Euh, mais voilà, voilà un peu où j'en suis. Euh, j'ai répondu avec des termes très vagues, je sais pas si...
Oui, mais au fond, euh, tu réponds, euh, tu réponds à ta propre question. C'est-à-dire qu'une fois qu'on a pris conscience que le fait d'avoir une aide ménagère,
une femme de ménage, une nounou, euh, Philippine qui s'occupe de nos enfants, qui s'occupe de notre maison, euh, quand, une fois qu'on a pris conscience du fait que bah,
on est en train de profiter d'un système, euh, qui est un système global, qui est un système mondial, qui a asservi une population féminine
issue de l'immigration, euh, pour faire toutes les tâches du care dans notre société, bah, on a déjà avancé.
C'est-à-dire comprendre qu'on est en train de nourrir quelque chose de systémique, c'est déjà un avancement et ça va nous permettre de, de, de, d'améliorer nos comportements individuels.
Euh, ça peut passer par du militantisme, ça peut passer par du don des associations, ça peut passer par le fait de lire des livres comme tu le dis, de conseiller des livres ou, ou d'a-, ou d'alerter autour de soi.
Et puis chacun fait à son niveau. Toi comme moi, on est journalistes, nos, nos façons d'agir, c'est plutôt par l'intellect, par la diffusion d'informations.
Bon ben, c'est nos façons d'agir. Mais euh, mais je pense qu'en fait le pas le plus difficile à accomplir, c'est la prise de conscience.
Et euh, et c'est, et c'est à partir de là, petit à petit, de modifier et d'adapter nos comportements à cette prise de conscience. Ça passe par-
En fait, ce qui est compliqué, c'est une fois, une fois la prise de conscience réalisée
Ben se rendre compte qu'on maintient le, nos privilèges sont toujours en place, on a toujours une aide ménagère, on a toujours des, des privilèges, euh,
vis-à-vis par exemple des, dans mon cas, des, des femmes ou des, des personnes racisées ou ce genre de choses.
Euh, donc y a, y a, y a une perpétuelle, euh, perpétuel questionnement de-
Bien sûr. Et puis y a pas de réponse toute faite, hein.
Non, c'est clair.
Par exemple, je pense,
euh, 'fin, c'est, c'est des problèmes qui sont très comparables où, euh, quand on, quand on prend conscience du fait que la fast fashion,
euh, 'fin, voilà, les vêtements pas chers qu'on peut acheter, euh, sont fabriqués au Bangladesh par des femmes payées dans des-- 'fin, et travaillant dans des conditions absolument désastreuses sur le plan humain,
euh, est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut boycotter, boycotter les vêtements made in, made in Bangladesh ?
Si tu parles aux syndicalistes du textile au Bangladesh, ils vont te dire : « Mais surtout pas. Si vous nous boycottez, vous nous privez de nos emplois, en fait.
Euh, par contre, nous donner du pouvoir, nous donner de l'argent, nous permettre de nous battre, euh, pour,
euh, pour renforcer nos, nos droits, pour obtenir des lois de protection des travailleurs et travailleuses au Bangladesh, oui, c'est une meilleure chose ».
Donc en fait, est-ce qu'il faut pas non plus être dans une espèce de posture paternaliste et occidentalo-centrée à se dire, euh : « Je vais plus acheter ces vêtements, je vais plus employer ces personnes », mais au contraire,
peut-être essayer de réfléchir différemment, comment leur donner du pouvoir ?
Euh, comment, euh, en fait, me, me, me sortir, m'enlever du centre ? Je suis pas au centre de cette histoire, en fait.
Mh.
Euh, ça peut être aussi intéressant. Peut-être que tu vois, ce, ce, ce-- je réfléchis un peu avec toi, là, je me sens-
Je t'en prie.
Une petite,
une petite branlette intellectuelle, là et tout, mais je trouve ça intéressant, tu vois. Est-ce que c'est pas encore hyper occidentalo-centré
et hyper une espèce de privilège blanc de se dire : « Qu'est-ce que je peux faire, en fait, pour sauver le monde ? »
Sans doute, oui.
Euh, voilà, très, très souvent dans les luttes afroféministes, on entend cette phrase : « Ne nous libérez pas, on s'en charge ».
Mh.
Euh, et finalement, peut-être qu'il faut mieux réfléchir à, à comment donner, euh, la, la possibilité, euh, pour ces femmes de reprendre le pouvoir, en fait, et, et de décider de leur destin et de maîtriser leur destin.
Et, euh, voilà, c'est, c'est une piste. C'est une piste.
Oui, oui. On n'arrivera pas à son échelle individuelle, quoi. C'est quelque chose de plus systémique.
Non, mais je pense aussi que quand on a conscience de ça, on modifie ses comportements presque inconsciemment. C'est-à-dire que peut-être que maintenant que t'as lu ce chapitre dans mon livre, tu ne vas plus t'adresser de la même façon,
euh, à cette personne ou peut-être envisager différemment le rôle, l'importance qu'elle a dans, dans ta vie.
Peut-être que tu vas la, mieux la payer, euh, j'en sais rien. Mais, euh, mais en tout cas, euh, je pense qu'il y a pas de petit geste, il y a pas de petite prise de conscience.
Toute prise de conscience est, est un, une avancée vers un monde plus juste.
Oui. Euh, tu commences ton livre en parlant de déconstruction au niveau du genre et ensuite au niveau de l'orientation sexuelle.
On a beaucoup parlé de lesbianisme politique avec, euh, avec Alice Coffin y a, y a deux ans.
Euh, y a une phrase, euh, dans ton livre qui m'a beaucoup posé question et je pense que toutes les femmes qui nous écoutent savent exactement de quoi tu parles, mais moi, je ne sais pas du tout.
Donc, je vais te poser la question, surtout pour tous les hommes qui nous écoutent.
La baise hétérosexuelle est de la soupe tiède. Non, c'est pas celle-là que tu viens de sortir parce que celle-là, on me la sort tout le temps par ailleurs.
C'est, c'est, euh, quand tu expliques : « Nous continuons, quoi qu'on décide, quoi qu'on constate, d'être tentées par la gratification instantanée que constitue le simple regard d'un homme posé sur nous ».
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler de ça ?
Waouh. Euh, ben en tout cas, c'est marrant que t'aies cité Alice Coffin juste avant parce que, euh, Alice Coffin, elle parle aussi dans son livre de, de cette difficulté qu'on peut avoir à se passer du regard des hommes.
Et, euh, et c'est pas, et c'est pas très surprenant parce que on grandit, euh, dans un monde où on nous apprend que l'autorité, euh, la justice, euh, la validation, le savoir, le pouvoir, euh, sont la plupart du temps incarnés par des hommes.
Donc, euh, finalement, se retrouver dans une situation où on n'a à aucun moment dans sa vie un homme qui vient valider nos faits, nos gestes, euh, notre apparence, etc.
Ça peut être déstabilisant. Euh, d'ailleurs, c'est en ça que le lesbianisme politique est une vraie proposition révolutionnaire.
Euh, voilà, ça, ça, ça commence...
Simone de Beauvoir, elle parle dans Le deuxième sexe, hein, c'est-- ah, je me rappelle plus de l'ex- de l'expression exacte, ce regard de considération,
euh, de considération tendre ou je sais plus, euh, que le père pose sur sa fille et que sa fille passera sa vie entière à rechercher à nouveau dans le regard d'un homme.
Euh, c'est... Ouais, je, je, je-
Quand,
quand, quand on parle de système de domination et qu'on observe des, des systèmes qui sont aptes à rendre
les, les populations dominées, à leur faire percevoir que le système est légitime, que c'est, que c'est ce qu'elles veulent, que c'est comme ça que ça doit être, etc.
Euh, c'est, c'est des systèmes qui à ce moment-là sont particulièrement difficiles à déconstruire, à révolutionner.
Euh, et, et quand je lis cette phrase de : « C'est très difficile de se passer du, du regard d'un homme » qui procure apparemment un petit kick de dopamine, je ne sais pas très bien.
C'est, c'est, c'est très étranger pour moi et c'est à ça que ça me fait penser, à ce, ce, cette, au fait que c'est, ça doit être difficile de, de s'en passer.
Euh, est-ce que tu as le souvenir d'où est-ce que ça t'est venu, toi, en tant que femme, le, le, cette idée, ce système comme quoi le regard de l'homme, c'est formidable ?
Je te l'ai dit, euh, voilà, 'fin, c'est, c'est une construction culturelle, une construction médiatique. On allume la télé, le président, c'est un homme qui nous dit quoi faire, quoi penser.
Voilà, le, le prof de philo, c'est un homme, le directeur de l'école, c'est un homme, euh, le, le-- je sais pas, moi, tu vois-
Non, non, j'ai bien compris, oui, mais c'est, c'est tellement-
Le, le, le directeur de l'Académie des César. 'Fin, tu vois, c'est toujours des trucs comme ça, en fait, qui font que c'est toujours les hommes qui décident et qui dirigent.
Et donc du coup, d'un seul coup, quand on se retrouve dans une société où y a plus, 'fin, dans un, dans un collectif où y a plus un homme qui, qui dit, qui-
Oui
Qui vient nous, nous valider, euh, c'est, c'est déroutant. Mais je te parle pas d'une expérience personnelle particulièrement, mais je te parle vraiment de ce qui peut se produire,
euh, dans, dans une vie banale d'une, d'une petite fille qui devient une femme quoi.
Oui, oui. Mais c'est, c'est, oui. Je pense que t'as compris que c'était tellement étranger à mon propre vécu que j'ai eu ça, j'ai fait what ? Quoi ?
Ouais, ouais.
À ce point-là. Et c'est pas la première fois que j'entends ça, mais à chaque fois, c'est, c'est très, c'est très étranger.
Euh, quelque chose que tu évoques pour, pour continuer sur cette idée-là, euh, tu dis : Les mythes de la narration hétérosexuelle sont en train de s'effondrer dans un joyeux bazar.
Je dirais qu'on peut diviser cette réflexion en deux branches qui sont en train de fleurir parallèlement en proposant deux voies pour se tirer de ce mauvais pas, les hétéro-optimistes et les sécessionnistes.
Euh, alors, très intéressant. Dans quel camp est-ce que tu es ?
Euh, bah moi, je suis dans les-- de fait, je vis parmi les hétéro-optimistes. Euh, je suis, je suis toujours-
Tu n'es pas une sécessionniste.
Euh, non. Euh, après, voilà, moi, je pense que les sécessionnistes, elles ont finalement presque pour, pour objectif les terres lesbiennes où je parle, je parle aussi de, de cette...
C'est d'ailleurs, c'est des endroits qui, qui revivent aujourd'hui. Dans les années soixante-dix, il y a beaucoup de lesbiennes qui ont décidé vraiment d'aller euh, de complètement sortir de la société et, et d'aller inventer
une nouvelle façon de vivre qui serait une façon vraiment concrètement éco-féministe, euh, sur des terres lesbiennes qui ont été un petit peu abandonnées pendant plusieurs décennies et qui sont, qui retrouvent un peu d'intérêt aujourd'hui.
Euh, et, et je trouve ça passionnant, je trouve ça, je trouve ça merveilleux. Euh, voilà, moi, je suis pas... Bon après, je suis pas hétérosexuelle, moi, je suis bisexuelle, c'est ce que j'explique dans le livre.
Donc, je pense que, euh, j'ai beau parfois relationner avec des hommes, ça fait, ça fait que je suis déjà sensée de l'hétérosexualité.
Euh, en revanche, je pense qu'effectivement, il est possible d'aménager un espace de, où on continue de vivre avec les hommes, de relationner avec eux, tout en s'étant libéré d'un certain nombre d'injonctions,
euh, liées à la famille, à nos modes de vie.
Il y a plein de façons de faire. Mais par contre, ce que je précise aussi dans le futur, c'est que c'est aussi un privilège que d'avoir l'espace d'inventer ces façons de faire.
Euh, voilà, je, effectivement, je vois autour de moi beaucoup de, beaucoup de femmes de ma génération, de mon milieu qui vont, euh, je sais pas moi...
Les relations ouvertes, ce genre de choses ?
Oui, voilà, ça peut être ça ou ça peut être le fait de se séparer du père de ses enfants tout en continuant à maintenir une, des super bonnes relations avec lui
ou de décider de vivre à part alors qu'on est en couple ou de décider de se mettre en commun avec des amis, d'acheter une maison et d'être plusieurs familles. Enfin,
c'est simplement dès l'instant où on va sortir de cette espèce de modèle de la famille nucléaire
qui en plus, c'est une aberration écologique, cette espèce de petite idée de voilà, on va avoir une maison avec une cuisine, un salon, une salle à manger, une salle de bain qui sera pour papa, maman et les enfants.
En vérité, c'est une construction culturelle. Les gens n'ont pas toujours vécu comme ça. C'est même relativement récent, cette façon d'envisager nos modes de vie.
Tu voudrais une grande salle pour toute la famille comme au Moyen Âge ?
Je dis pas que je voudrais, je dis que ça pourrait être une possibilité. Et euh, et voilà, Geneviève Pruvost, qui est une chercheuse éco-féministe que je cite dans mon, dans mon chapitre cinq,
elle parle de la, de la maisonnée comme un espace où finalement,
les choses s'agencent de façon beaucoup plus vaste que la simple famille nucléaire.
Et enfin, là, en l'espace de, de, de, d'une, d'une réponse, je t'ai exploré tout un tas de possibles.
Oui, l'éco-féminisme, c'est ça.
Non, mais surtout, voilà, je suis, encore une fois, je suis pas en train de dire : Il faut vivre comme ci, il faut arrêter de vivre comme ça.
Je suis en train d'essayer de démontrer qu'à travers la pensée féministe, en fait, on peut commencer à imaginer de multiples possibles et de multiples configurations, euh, sans oublier évidemment le célibat
et le fait de passer une vie sans être en couple, sans avoir d'enfant et que ça ne soit pas considéré comme un échec.
Oui, c'est très stigmatisé.
Bah, c'est ça, c'est fou quand même. C'est-à-dire que quand je dis que l'hétérosexualité est un régime politique, je dis ça notamment.
C'est-à-dire qu'on considère-- on a inventé un mot, quand on y pense, le mot célibataire, c'est dingue. On a créé un mot pour désigner une personne qui vit sa vie seule et indépendamment d'une autre personne.
Et on stigmatise les personnes qui n'ont pas ou qui n'ont jamais eu de relation sexuelle.
Voilà, exactement, tout à fait. On stigmatise les femmes qui n'ont pas d'enfant à quarante ans. Euh, et donc, en fait, finalement, sortir de l'hétérosexualité, euh, c'est pas forcément devenir lesbienne, c'est pas forcément quitter, euh,
voilà, aller vivre sur des terres lesbiennes, même si je trouve que c'est une solution vraiment très efficace et très joyeuse.
Et, et je suis tellement heureuse qu'il y ait des femmes qui se retrouvent dans ces solutions-là et qui soient en train d'inventer de nouvelles façons de faire société entre femmes.
Mais, mais il y a, il y a mille autres possibilités,
mille autres possibles à inventer. Et tout ce que je, tout ce que je dis, c'est qu'on devrait pouvoir être libres en fait d'être nous-mêmes, d'aimer qui on veut, de vivre comme on veut et, et d'échapper...
Il y a une image qui m'est venue à l'esprit pendant que j'écrivais le livre. Je pensais au petit drapeau de la Manif pour tous,
qui est cette horrible organisation qui a cherché vraiment, qui s'est mobilisée pour lutter contre le droit pour les personnes homosexuelles de se marier et d'avoir des enfants.
Et leur drapeau, c'est un papa, une maman, un petit garçon et une petite fille. Moi, je pense que ce symbole, cette image, ça montre bien,
euh, la direction, euh, enfin, que, que finalement, il existe un mouvement politique qui cherche à nous imposer cette vision, euh, de, du bonheur, de la famille qui est dogmatique, qui est fascisante et, et, et il faut qu'on puisse absolument,
euh, inventer d'autres possibilités, même si, je tiens à le préciser,
on peut être aussi très heureux en couple hétérosexuel, on peut adorer être maman et, et que voilà, c'est, c'est une possibilité Aussi.
Oui. J'étais, j'étais très séduit par le, le, le propos de, d'Alice Coffin et cette idée de tiens, même si,
euh, même si on est une femme hétéro, on peut décider de se passer des hommes, on peut remettre ça en question, on peut chercher un- une autre façon de, d'organiser, euh, sa vie affective.
Euh, ce qui, ce qui est plus compliqué évidemment, c'est, euh, quand on annonce ça à un homme, euh, ça, ça on va pas, on va pas forcément résoudre cette question-là aujourd'hui, mais un homme à qui on annonce : tiens, finalement, en fait,
je vais peut-être, je vais peut-être devenir lesbienne poli-politique, je vais peut-être partir vivre dans les contrées lesbiennes, ça, c'est, c'est, c'est évidemment toujours douloureux, mais, mais bon, ça c'est pas...
on s'en fout en fait.
Bah non, on s'en fout pas. Évidemment qu'on peut pas s'en foutre. Sinon on va construire un monde où il y aura beaucoup trop de gens, euh, malheureux.
Euh, on s'en fout pas. Il faut, il faut discuter de tout ça, discuter de tout ça avec les hommes, leur proposer d'aller eux aussi, euh, peut-être vers des contrées d'homosexualité politique si ça se trouve ça les intéressera.
Ouais. Alors une phrase aussi. Je, je, j'isole toujours les petites phrases qui, qui m'interpellent, t'as, t'as remarqué.
À un moment, tu dis que, euh, MeToo t'épuise et que MeToo était un échec. Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer ? Parce que c'est très, encore une fois, très radical.
Oui, c'est un peu provocateur.
Voilà.
Euh, alors, euh, oui, et je me-- vraiment, au fil de la promotion de mon livre, je me rends compte que cette phrase hors contexte, euh, ne passe pas du tout, parce que c'est pas ce que je veux dire, euh, 'fin-
C'est l'occasion de le recontextualiser.
Ouais, après, je le fais, je le fais souvent parce que cette phrase, elle interpelle beaucoup. Donc voilà, j'ai, j'ai réussi mon coup, j'ai fait, j'ai fait parler.
Euh, alors MeToo, euh,
est un succès pour, euh, un certain nombre de raisons. Euh, MeToo a certainement fait beaucoup de bien, a apporté beaucoup de réparation aux victimes de violences sexuelles, euh, celles qui ont parlé, euh, celles qui n'ont pas parlé aussi.
Parce que le fait de se sentir moins seul, euh, déjà, je pense, fait beaucoup de bien, euh, dans le cas de, de, de ces violences qui sont souvent des traumatismes qui imposent le silence, un silence qui peut durer parfois des vies entières.
Donc, euh, en cela, MeToo, oui, a probablement été un apaisement. Euh, il me semble aussi que MeToo a peut-être
fait émerger, euh, dans l'espace public une, une conversation sur le consentement qui probablement va à terme changer les façons dont on fait l'amour.
Euh, je pense qu'il y a une jeune génération aujourd'hui qui envisage la sexualité dans des termes vraiment très différents de ceux qui étaient les miens, voilà, il y a, il y a une trentaine d'années.
Trente, non, peut-être pas, j'exagère, je suis pas si vieille que ça. Il y a une vingtaine d'années, euh, quand, quand, quand, voilà, quand ma vie sexuelle a commencé.
Donc, euh, donc super, bravo, génial. Au-delà de ça, euh, je ne pense pas que ce soit au fond très différent de ce que ci-- de ce qu'il se produisait dans les années soixante-dix.
C'est ça aussi la prise de conscience que j'ai eue, c'est que dans les années soixante-dix, il y avait déjà des femmes qui se mobilisaient, euh, pour parler du viol.
Euh, il y avait déjà des cercles de paroles non mixtes qui se créaient, où les femmes témoignaient des violences sexuelles qu'elles avaient subies,
recevaient du réconfort et du soutien d'autres femmes, de la sororité, du je te crois, tu n'es pas seule.
C'était déjà ça à l'époque. Il y avait déjà l'appel par les féministes à, à parler de consentement, à faire de l'éducation sexuelle, etc.
Et ce qui me désespère, c'est de me dire que cette conversation émerge à nouveau, euh, quasiment cinquante ans plus tard, euh, selon des termes assez similaires.
Sauf que la conversation, elle est plus beaucoup plus large. Au lieu d'être cinq mille femmes, on est peut-être cinq cent mille aujourd'hui, mais qu'au niveau médiatique, au niveau politique, au niveau, euh,
vraiment, euh, systémique, on n'a toujours pas compris de quoi on était en train de parler.
Et, et, et je trouve qu'il y a quelque chose, notamment dans le tra- dans le traitement médiatique du viol, euh, qui montre que vraiment, on est à côté de la plaque,
euh, on a l'impression encore que MeToo, c'est une succession de scandales, alors qu'en réalité ça devrait être la prise de conscience du caractère systémique du viol.
Et on en a parlé longuement tout à l'heure, donc je vais pas, je vais pas revenir dessus. Mais, euh, mais voilà. En tout cas, je pense que, euh, MeToo a été un,
un, un, une réussite du côté de l'organisation, euh, féministe, du côté de celles et ceux d'ailleurs qui en parlaient.
Mais, mais ça reste un échec dans sa réception.
Mh. Ça n'a pas bousculé le système, euh, avec l'ampleur que tu aurais espéré et donc c'est un échec.
Bah oui.
Un échec partiel.
Je sais pas. Je pense qu'on manque de recul en fait. L'autre jour, je parlais avec une amie, je disais : tu te rends compte, ça fait cinq ans et on a toujours pas nan-nan.
Et elle me disait, euh : mais Lauren, ça fait que cinq ans en fait. Et euh, et c'est vrai que le fait qu'elle me dise ça, ça m'a aussi fait réfléchir en me demandant peut-être que je suis impatiente en fait.
Peut-être qu'il faut dix, quinze, vingt ans de recul pour vraiment observer les changements que va amener MeToo. Mais quand même, euh, je trouve que
quand on voit la façon en fait dont les femmes qui ont parlé dans l'espace public, notamment en France, et c'est des femmes que j'ai interviewées, des Vanessa Springora, des Sandrine Rousseau,
des Flavie Flament ou autres, euh, quand je vois que finalement ce qui résulte de leur prise de parole, c'est souvent du cyberharcèlement, on les accuse de mentir.
C'est des vies entières consacrées à devoir se battre pour prouver qu'on a raison et qu'on ne ment pas et que, euh, je me dis quand même, euh, ça devrait pas être aussi difficile pour elles.
Mh. Et à partir de là, euh, le, le, le-- est-ce que, est-ce que tu, est-ce que tu... Oui, alors, j'ai, j'ai ce grand défaut en interview, c'est que je demande souvent aux gens de prédire l'avenir Ça marche pas trop.
Mais est-ce que, est-ce que, est-ce que tu fais partie de celles qui estiment qu'il y aura une nouvelle explosion, un nouveau, entre guillemets, MeToo qui frappera encore plus dur, encore plus fort ?
Ou bien est-ce que tu seras plutôt dans celles qui prônent un, un dialogue plus doux ? Comment est-ce que tu, comment est-ce que tu anticipes les choses ?
Ah non, effectivement, je veux pas... Enfin, après, j'ai écrit un livre qui s'appelle Futur, donc-
Voilà .
Je, je peux pas non plus te dire, je veux pas prédire l'avenir puisque j'ai littéralement proposé un avenir. Après, c'est un avenir que je, oui, que je suggère, que je propose.
Malheureusement, je suis quand même assez pessimiste sur l'avenir. Euh, c'est-à-dire que j'ai écrit ce livre que beaucoup de personnes décrivent comme optimiste, euh, où justement, je parle de cet apaisement possible, de ce dialogue possible.
Non violent.
Où je mets, voilà, où je mets de l'espoir et tout. Je l'ai écrit parce que j'étais désespérée, parce que j'étais pessimiste, parce que j'ai vraiment l'impression qu'on se dirige vers, vers le fascisme, euh, que, que, il y a de plus en plus
de, de remises en question de ces avancées qu'on a péniblement obtenues ces dernières années en termes de droits, notamment pour les personnes LGBT, mais aussi, voilà, les droits-
Avortement.
Basiques reproductifs pour les femmes. Et euh, et j'ai peur que ça recule en fait. Euh, et j'espère qu'il y aura d'autres mouvements MeToo, d'autres vagues, qu'on va pouvoir continuer de lutter, d'aller nombreuses dans les rues, manifester, etc.
etc. Lancer des hashtags, nous mobiliser.
Mais, mais j'ai peur que demain, ça devienne compliqué.
En tout cas, je sais que si l'extrême droite arrive au pouvoir en France, tout comme elle est arrivée au pouvoir aux États-Unis ou en Italie ou ailleurs dans le monde, euh, ça risque d'être vraiment compliqué de continuer de, de parler de tout ça.
C'est clair. Ce que j'évoque dans le livre aussi, c'est qu'il y a eu un court moment au début de la pandémie où tu disais : Mais c'est bon, c'est résolu, c'est dans la poche, on va, on va y arriver.
On va enfin prendre conscience du fait que comme les femmes sont, euh, vraiment contraintes à rester enfermées chez elles avec leur mari, ça va, ça va arriver sur le, le, le devant, le devant des caméras, on va enfin en parler.
Euh, finalement, non. Comment est-ce que tu expliques ce, le fait que ça n'a, ça n'a pas, ça n'a pas fonctionné ?
Bah, je sais pas. Le patriarcat, j'imagine.
Oui, bonne réponse.
Le patriarcat, le fait qu'on n'écoute pas les féministes, le fait que personne ne, ne, ne soit suffisamment leur personne.
Heureusement, non, il y a des gens qui s'y intéressent.
Il y a des livres qui sont lus et vendus et écrits, mais il y a cette pensée du care qui est vraiment une pensée passionnante qui permet de, de, de comprendre
une grande partie des interactions sociales et qui pourrait avoir un impact très fort sur les politiques publiques si c'était tenu, si les gens en tenaient compte.
Mais malheureusement, peu de gens connaissent ça.
Tu dis : On n'écoute pas les féministes. Toi, tu as évidemment un regard de journaliste, un regard sur la structure des médias en France en particulier.
Euh, qu'est-ce qui, qu'est-ce qui fait que les chaînes d'info, par exemple, ou même les chaînes généralistes,
n'accordent pas de crédit, euh, n'accordent pas autant de crédit, en tout cas, à la parole féministe qu'à celle des hommes en costume cravate, experts, très...
comme ça. Euh, qu'est-ce qui, qu'est-ce qui fait dans le système médiatique, bon, tu vas me dire, le patriarcat, mais...
Bah oui, mais oui, déjà, il y a un espèce de biais qui consiste à, à estimer qu'une parole d'expert est forcément une parole masculine.
Euh, voilà, ça, c'est quelque chose que j'expliquais déjà dans Présentes. Le temps de parole des femmes dans les médias, c'est vingt-cinq pour cent.
Le temps de parole des expertes parmi les experts et expertes, c'est treize pour cent. Donc, plus, en fait, on cherche une parole d'autorité, moins on donne la parole aux femmes.
Euh, ça, bon, c'est quelque chose qui a été expliqué maintes fois, notamment par Rebecca Solnit, qui est une journaliste américaine qui a écrit Ces hommes qui m'expliquent la vie.
Excellent livre. Euh, voilà, ça, ça a été... Je cherche le nom d'un, d'une autre autrice, Les femmes et le pouvoir. Euh, je crois que c'est Mary, Mary Beard qui explique tout ça très bien.
Euh, après, dans les médias français, le véritable problème, c'est que ces médias sont détenus par des milliardaires ou des personnes très riches en tout cas, qui portent des idées fondamentalement conservatrices.
Et je pense qu'il faut le dire, je veux dire, c'est politique. On ne donne pas la parole aux féministes, pas parce qu'on oublie hein, c'est parce qu'on n'aime pas ce que disent les féministes.
On n'est pas d'accord avec ce que disent les féministes. Le retournement du monde qu'on propose, notre programme politique ne plaît pas, euh, aux grands médias français.
Euh et, et si on est, si on nous donne pas la parole, enfin, on donne pas la parole aux féministes, on donne pas non plus la parole aux écologistes hein.
Euh, c'est, c'est parce que c'est des programmes politiques qui n'arrangent pas les affaires, euh, des grands patrons de médias.
Et, et vraiment, je suis pas dans un délire complotiste. Quand je dis ça, il suffit vraiment de regarder la façon dont sont structurés les médias français.
Il suf- il suffit de regarder la façon dont Bolloré, peu à peu, met la main sur, euh, sur, euh, des médias et des maisons d'édition.
Mais j'aurais pu parler aussi de LVMH ou, ou d'autres grands groupes qui sont toujours détenus par, par des hommes très riches.
Euh, c'est, c'est vraiment, euh, une démarche politique que de, que d'ignorer nos discours, que de les caricaturer, euh, que de nous présenter aussi systématiquement, il y a cette espèce d'expression là qui revient sans cesse de néo-féministes.
Euh, à vouloir nous faire passer pour des espèces de folles, euh, super, euh, radicales, déconnectées du réel. Euh, en plus, on nous fait dire tout et n'importe quoi.
Un jour, euh, on, on, on veut abolir le genre et pour nous, il y a plus d'hommes ni de femmes. Le lendemain, on déteste les hommes et enfin, genre, faut savoir en fait comment on est quoi.
C'est ça.
Euh, enfin bref, donc du coup, euh, je pense que c'est, c'est une censure qui est une censure politique et ce sont nos idées politiques, euh, à qui on, on, on barre la route.
Et, et donc là, les grands médias effectivement possédés par les hommes milliardaires, euh, les nouveaux médias, les réseaux sociaux, eux aussi,
donc c'est assez algorithmique, mais influencé, on l'a vu avec Elon Musk, y a des, des idées qui veulent être en particulier mises en avant, enfin voilà.
Et même la façon dont fonctionne l'algorithme Instagram est très défavorable aux féministes hein. Euh, je veux dire cette espèce de censure, bon, c'est une, c'est une histoire assez, euh, assez ancienne, mais c'est, c'est encore d'actualité,
le, la, la censure, euh, des, des, des seins, des tétons
féminins, c'est une aberration.
Enfin, est-ce qu'on a besoin de meilleures preuves pour, pour, pour montrer que c'est aussi un, que l'algorithme est tout aussi patriarcal que la société ?
Sur Twitch, cela dit, si on montre un téton masculin, on se fait, on se fait éjecter aussi.
Bon ben à la rigueur, voilà, mais au moins, il y a une cohérence. Non, mais il y a une cohérence. Moi, enfin, moi, j'ai-
C'est pas le cas sur Instagram ?
S'il y a des... Ah, mais non.
Ok, ok.
Les tétons masculins passent.
D'accord.
C'est ça l'aberration.
En effet, en effet, en effet.
Et donc oui, ça, ça va être difficile de, d'imaginer un futur. Enfin, on peut être optimiste à la fois parce que les grands médias, les médias, les médias de télévision, les grandes chaînes sont de moins en moins regardés par le public jeune.
Donc, on peut imaginer une transition, mais, euh, disons que la, la fachosphère est aussi très présente sur les réseaux.
Donc c'est, c'est pas forcément plus, plus gai, euh, dans cette perspective-là. Donc c'est effectivement un futur sombre que, qu'on, qu'on voit devant nous, je pense, en ce qui concerne en tout cas les médias.
Ben je, ouais, je sais pas et en même temps, euh, il y a aussi tellement de nouveaux médias qui se créent, il y a tellement d'espaces alternatifs pour s'informer.
Euh, y a aussi, euh, voilà, des, des, des vidéos tellement didactiques qui sont produites tous les jours sur YouTube, sur Instagram, sur TikTok,
qui vulgarisent des textes féministes qui, autre, qui il y a encore cinq ou six ans étaient même pas, même pas,
on pouvait même pas lire dans une bibliothèque ou en librairie parce qu'ils étaient pas réédités, qu'on les trouvait plus.
Donc, euh, je sais pas. Là, j'ai eu l'impression, euh, quand il y a eu le, la, tout récemment, l'élection de midterms aux États-Unis où Trump et ses alliés annonçaient une red wave, qu'on allait voir vraiment-
Il s'est planté.
Voilà, ben en fait, il s'est planté parce qu'il y a eu un vote de la génération Z. Et puis c'est des gens qui avaient peut-être pas le droit, le droit de vote en 2016 quand il a été élu président et qui maintenant en l'ont.
Et qui ont été très peu sondés.
Et qui ont été peu sondés et dont on connaît mal les comportements parce qu'ils sont pas, euh, ils sont pas sondés au téléphone, ils sont sur Instagram, sur TikTok, etc.
Ils ont pas de téléphone.
Ils ont pas de téléphone, ils ont juste un, un, un smartphone. Bref, et, et ces gens, euh, ces jeunes personnes, évidemment, ont, ont voté pour, euh, les, pour les droits LGBT, pour le droit à l'avortement.
C'est aussi les femmes noires qui sont mobilisées, qui sont massivement allées aux urnes. C'est aussi les femmes qui ont été consultées sur leur, sur le droit à l'IVG, dans des États où il y avait, euh,
un espèce de truc moitié démocrate, moitié conservateur, ben le droit à l'IVG, en fait, on touche pas pour beaucoup de femmes.
Donc en fait, il y a eu un espèce de, ben non, il y a pas eu de red wave en fait. Il y a eu une mobilisation, un, un contre-pouvoir qui était pas forcément tout à fait identifié par les grands médias, mais qui pourtant était là.
Et ça m'a redonné de l'espoir. Je me suis dit, euh, bon, peut-être qu'on est plus nombreux et nombreuses que, que j'ai un peu l'impression parfois qu'on est.
C'est intéressant parce qu'on a, on a des, régulièrement des signaux
contraires à ce niveau-là. Parfois, effectivement, comme l'actualité récente l'a montré, la génération, la jeune génération, euh, est extrêmement progressiste et vote en faveur des droits des minorités.
Et à d'autres moments, on nous explique que le parti d'Éric Zemmour a beaucoup de succès chez la jeune génération, des jeunes hommes, etc.
Donc, il y a, il y a, bon, c'est, c'est, c'est pas binaire, je crois. Et il y a effectivement une grande polarisation. J'ai l'impression que les jeunes sont soit, soit très très progressistes et,
et font la révolution dont tu parles dans ton livre futur, soit extrêmement conservateurs et, et-
Ouais.
Voilà, ouais, ouais.
Oui, t'as pas tort. Effectivement, je pense que c'est une des caractéristiques du débat politique ces prochaines années, c'est qu'il va être très polarisé.
Voilà, voilà. Mais on ne va pas, on ne va pas, on ne va pas pouvoir résoudre cette question-là ici, maintenant, j'en ai peur.
Euh, donc ce que, ce que, ce que tu, ce que tu exprimes quand tu termines ton livre, c'est que tu as envie d'un futur non violent.
Tu expliques que la, la violence crée des structures de domination au sein de, du groupe qui cherche la vengeance. Mais, euh, est-ce que tu souhaiterais que les hommes aient conscience et peur de la violence de la part des femmes ?
Est-ce que, euh, parce que pour l'instant, elle est invisibilisée, on la considère même pas. C'est, c'est même pas, pas une option, c'est même pas imaginable, la, la, la violence de la part des femmes.
Euh, alors, tu ne souhaites pas la violence de la part des femmes, mais est-ce que tu souhaiterais qu'elle soit crainte ?
Que la possibilité soit envisagée ?
C'est, c'est une, c'est une question, euh, intéressante que tu poses. Euh, je peux pas souhaiter la peur. Je peux pas souhaiter que qui que ce soit ait peur.
Très Bisounours, en effet.
Moi, je suis vraiment sur l'amour, là. Je suis assez sur l'amour. Non, je peux pas, je peux pas souhaiter la peur. Surtout que finalement, quand on voit la, la façon dont, dont MeToo est accueilli, euh, les hommes ont peur.
Euh, c'est, et ça fait pas beaucoup avancer les choses.
C'est-à-dire que peur de l'appareil judiciaire et puis ils se sont rendus compte qu'en fait-
Non, ils ont peur, ils ont peur des tweets, ils ont peur du post Instagram, ils ont peur qu'on les balance.
La réputation, ouais.
Voilà. Et euh, et je pense pas que cette peur, euh, fasse réellement avancer les choses sur le plan, sur le plan global.
Je, je pense pas que la peur soit un outil politique valable. Alors évidemment, ce que tu soulèves à travers cette question, c'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus complexe qui concerne l'invisibilisation de la violence des femmes.
Et on voit que quand cette violence, elle est exercée, il y a un effet de surprise, que personne s'attend. Chaque fois qu'il y a une femme qui accomplit un attentat terroriste ou un fait divers ou un meurtre, on glose sans fin sur son genre.
Oui, on dit qu'elle est folle.
On dit qu'elle est folle, etc. Mais euh, mais donc ça, c'est une question qui se pose, s'il faut complètement désessentialiser en fait et sortir de cette idée que les femmes seraient naturellement douces et les hommes naturellement violents.
Parce que ça n'est pas ça. Tout être humain est capable de violence. Tout être humain est capable de douceur, quel que soit son genre.
J'en suis absolument convaincue. Euh, donc voilà, c'est deux mécanismes qui sont différents, selon moi, celui de visibiliser cette violence comme une possibilité.
Mais par contre, non, je veux pas susciter la peur, je veux susciter l'égalité.
Ok. Voilà. Donc, tu restes effectivement très cohérente. Et donc, tu veux pas susciter la peur. Euh, ce que tu expliques, c'est qu'il faut apprendre à réparer plutôt qu'à punir.
Donc ça, c'est cohérent avec ce qu'on disait, en particulier sur la justice réparatrice. Euh, donc vraiment un message que tu portes et justement plein de douceur.
Donc, un homme pourrait le porter aussi. Donc, si on reste cohérent avec ce que tu nous expliques. Donc oui, un message plein de, d'inclusivité, plein d'amour, plein de douceur.
Tu cherches à éjecter de notre société la violence, les oppressions. Et jusqu'à présent, dans tes travaux, dans tes livres, dans tes podcasts, tu as surtout donné la place à des discours de femmes.
Et tu termines ton livre en disant : Maintenant, j'aimerais plutôt interviewer des hommes. Alors, tu m'as interviewé pendant deux minutes tout à l'heure.
Euh, mais qu'est-ce qui te donne cette envie ?
Attention, je ne crois pas avoir dit j'aimerais plutôt. Euh, je me dis que j'aimerais aussi.
Ma langue a buggé.
Non, non, non, mais je le précise parce que je te jure, moi, je suis moi-même un peu terrifiée de dire ça, parce que j'ai
quand même bâti ma carrière, ma réputation et tout mon travail féministe sur le fait de donner la parole aux femmes, qui était une nécessité, qui était une urgence, vu la
très faible présence des femmes dans les médias.
Et je veux surtout pas dire : Maintenant, c'est bon, j'ai rééquilibré les choses. Nous allons pouvoir passer à la partie...
Non, il faut encore mettre en avant la parole des femmes, etc. Mais j'ai l'impression que si j'interviewais les hommes, des hommes avec mon prisme de lecture du monde à moi, ce serait pas inintéressant.
C'est-à-dire que oui, on entend beaucoup les hommes, on n'en peut plus d'entendre les hommes nous raconter leur life, leurs émotions, leurs états d'âme, etc.
Mais est-ce qu'on les entend vraiment déconstruire leur parcours de genre ? Est-ce qu'on les entend vraiment avoir un espace pour raconter les violences
peut-être qu'ils ont infligées avec une écoute qui serait une écoute bienveillante, non jugeante ?
Est-ce qu'on a entendu les hommes parler des violences qu'ils avaient peut-être subies dans leur enfance ? Est-ce que les hommes, ils ont un espace comme ça, un espace safe pour se confier là-dessus ?
Et ça, je me suis interrogée parce que j'ai reçu beaucoup de mails d'hommes qui avaient été victimes de violences sexuelles dans leur enfance et qui n'avaient nulle part
pour en parler, qui trouvaient qu'en parler à cette podcasteuse féministe qui avait l'air conciliante, c'était peut-être une bonne solution.
Et d'ailleurs, je suis sûre que ça les a soulagés. Donc euh, c'est ça que je me dis.
L'idée, ce n'est pas de tendre,
j'allais dire bêtement, il n'y a aucune façon bête de tendre le micro, mais tout simplement, disons, le micro à des hommes pour qu'ils me racontent leur vie sous leurs propres termes, mais c'est plutôt de proposer une grille d'entretien féministe à des hommes.
Et je pense que ce serait intéressant. Et je pense aussi qu'il est temps que les hommes se mouillent et viennent vraiment prendre des coups aussi pour nous.
Parce que je trouve que cet acquiescement, l'acquiescement un peu silencieux qu'on a pu obtenir de beaucoup d'hommes dits alliés dans nos luttes, genre : Ouais, vas-y, je suis avec toi.
Yes, vive les meufs.
Oui, c'est ça. Les tweets d'encouragement de : C'est trop bien ce que tu fais. Puis quand tu te fais harceler-
Ça suffit plus.
Je mets pas les gants de boxe, je me mouille pas.
Voilà. Et puis moi, j'ai vraiment envie de voir des hommes dire : Les hommes violent. Let's go. Diffuser les chiffres. Euh, j'ai envie de voir des hommes.
Moi, quand je vais manifester devant l'ambassade de Pologne pour le droit à l'IVG, je voudrais qu'il y ait des hommes qui soient là, parce qu'à la fin, on va se faire nasser, on va se faire gazer et c'est nous, c'est nos yeux qui vont pleurer.
Euh, enfin, ce que je voudrais, c'est justement un engagement un peu plus grand. Et je me dis que si je tends mon micro à des hommes et que je donne l'occasion à des hommes
de dire, d'avoir de vraies prises de parole féministes dans l'espace public, ça pourrait faire avancer les choses.
Enfin, je sais pas. Parfois, je me dis que peut-être qu'un homme peut avoir aussi un impact parfois plus fort sur certains milieux, notamment auprès des autres hommes.
Et de par ses privilèges, de par sa position.
Et de par ses privilèges. Voilà. Donc euh, c'est pour ça que moi, j'aurais tendance à t'autoriser à te dire féministe, même si je veux surtout pas contredire mes consœurs qui t'ont dit l'inverse.
On a des façons de voir les choses qui sont peut-être différentes. Il y a des façons de faire. Euh, si tu prends pas toute la place, si tu demandes pas des médailles, je pense que c'est ok.
Parce que si tu as sincèrement compris ce que je raconte dans ce livre, si tu as sincèrement envie de diffuser l'éco-féminisme et la pensée du care, mais je t'en supplie, fais-le quoi.
Tout à fait. J'adhère tout à fait à l'idée de dire que les hommes violent et qu'il y a tous les systèmes dont on va parler aujourd'hui ensemble qui sont en place.
Il faut, j'adhère tout à fait à l'idée de les dénoncer avec mes invités. Par contre, mettre des gants de boxe et me faire taper dessus sur Twitter, là je, je suis trop bisounours en fait.
Je, je, ça me, je souffre. Je, est-ce que, est-ce que, est-ce que je, est-ce que je dois souffrir avec vous ? Est-ce que je dois-
Je sais pas, moi, j'y vais plus sur Twitter hein.
Ouais, ouais.
C'est pas moi qui vais te le reprocher hein. Moi, c'est pareil, je, je, j'estime que j'ai eu ma part et que c'est bon.
Moi, j'y suis, mais on me laisse tranquille parce que je suis un homme blanc. Donc c'est, donc c'est chill. Mais-
Non, mais puis je suis pas forcément sûre que finalement, c'est la façon la plus efficace de faire avancer un débat.
C'est des causes perdues, les trolls, donc euh.
Ouais. Non, mais je suis d'accord. Je, je viens d'admettre que c'est pas facile de se positionner et de trouver son, sa, sa, sa juste place.
Mais bon euh, voilà, c'est, c'est aussi OK de se tromper, de se faire engueuler,
peut-être tenter des trucs. C'est sûr que si demain, tu te, tu prenais l'initiative de lancer une pétition ou je sais pas quoi, tu risques de te faire, de te faire engueuler parce que tu prends tout l'espace médiatique et tout. Mais,
mais voilà, il y a quand même beaucoup d'endroits où, où, où les hommes ont un rôle hyper important à jouer.
Euh, enfin, je veux dire, on, on vit avec vous quoi, on partage le monde avec vous et ce qu'on raconte, ça vous concerne au premier chef, donc euh.-
Au premier chef ?
C'est difficile-- Bah oui, au premier égalité avec nous quoi.
C'est ça, ouais.
Cinquante cinquante quoi.
C'est ça. Très bien. Lauren, je dois te libérer puisque tu dois, tu dois filer à une autre interview. Je te remercie pour ces Septante Minutes passées ensemble.
C'était septante minutes ?
Euh, soixante-neuf.
Waouh, incroyable.
Soixante-neuf vingt-trois.
Excellent.
Le temps, le temps est vite passé.
Très belle maîtrise du temps. Bah merci à toi pour l'invitation.
Voilà et je te dis à très bientôt, au revoir. C'est déjà tout pour ces Septante Minutes Avec Lauren Bastide. J'espère que vous en avez bien profité.
Comme je le disais en début d'épisode, je vous dois quelques explications en ce qui concerne le timing de publication absolument désastreux de ces dernières semaines.
Euh, je suis tombé terriblement malade puisque, euh, ben voilà, je suis tombé amoureux. J'ai une copine. C'est tragique, mais c'est comme ça.
Ça a détruit toute ma productivité, mais même pas seulement au niveau de mon podcast. Rendez-vous compte, je n'ai même plus le temps de jouer aux jeux vidéo.
Rendez-vous compte. Donc ça signifie que malgré tout, le podcast continue, ça va de soi. Mais disons que je tiens, je garantis un petit peu moins ce qui va se passer dans les mois à venir.
Ce que je peux déjà vous promettre, c'est que Myriam Leroy revient dans quelques semaines dans Septante Minutes Avec pour parler de son nouveau roman, dans lequel il y aura certainement un angle féministe et pas seulement.
Je recevrai également une personne spécialisée en intelligence artificielle pour un sujet un peu plus tech. Ça faisait longtemps, mais c'est, ça fait partie des sujets que j'adore traiter aussi.
Et tout ça dès le mois de janvier. Je vous souhaite déjà une belle et merveilleuse année 2023. J'espère que 2022 s'est bien passée pour vous et je vous embrasse très fort.
Salut salut !